We've been together for a while now, and
I just want to take a step back and say,
thanks for bearing with us,
this is a ton of information.
You've learned how to create
some really cool features using
the Google Maps APIs, using a drawing
layer, making unique styles,
showing users distances and
directions, and
getting back detailed places
of interest information.
>> You may be wondering what this is.
Well, it's Google's gift to you,
and we'll show you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[SOUND] It's the keys to the castle.
You see,
now that you know how to use them,
the Google Maps APIs
are yours to use for free.
[SOUND]
>> In the next few lessons, will go over
some important practical details you
need to know while flexing your creative
muscles, and using location services,
and visualizations in your sites.
>> So far, you've been using the API
keys you generated in the very beginning
of the course to access most of
the functionality we've covered.
You've also already enabled
the APIs that you've used so far.
>> We're going to go over the other
important things that you can and should
be doing within the Google Developers
Console, now that you're a pro.
>> The first thing you should be
aware of is the ability to monitor
the usage of your API key.
You should know that there is
an allotted number of what we call
map loads,
that you can use as a free user.
Every time you load a Google map, using
the initialized function that we've seen
to create a map object,
you use one map look.
You have more than enough quota to
experiment freely and develop apps.
See the documentation linked in the
instructor notes for up-to-date amounts.
You can see how many you use over
time within the developer's console.
And we'll practice that soon.
>> Next, in order to increase
the security of your API key,
you can whitelist domains
which are able to use it.
For example, after making my site,
I could whitelist
EmilysNYCHouseHunter.com.
And then, that will be the only site
that can make requests using that key.
When making a request using that
API key, they'll go through.
If any other domain,
like AjaysNYCHousHunter.com,
attempts to do so,
they would get an error.
That way, nobody accidentally
starts to use my key,
using up all my map loads or
not so accidentally.
It's always important
to protect yourself.
Quota theft is not a common occurrence,
but we care about security here.
>> Now, as I said, there is a fair
amount of quota given for free.
Most websites and
applications will stay within this.
However, if you consistently
generate a high amount of traffic,
you just limit supply.
And you'll need to pay for extra usage.
You can do this by enabling billing
within the developers console.
You can also choose to put
an enforced cap on your usage
to make sure you don't
go over a certain limit.
See the documentation in the instructor
notes for how to do this.
>> The next thing to be aware of,
has to do with using the services.
Both client and server side.
In general, there are two types of
caps that we have on service usage.
Queries per day,
also known as QPD, which is the total
number of requests made in one day.
And queries per second,
or QPS, which as it sounds is the number
of requests made in one second.
The developer documentation has
specifics on the limitations for
each web service.
Remember how we talked about web
service response codes before?
>> Right, we wanted that okay response.
If you ever see the over
query limit response code,
it means you've hit one of these QPD or
QPS limits.
Now, try logging into the Google
developer's console and
viewing your projects usage so far.